the president says negotiations with
North Korea might not have been possible
without the tragic death of American
student otto warmbier who died after
being released from a North Korean
prison one year ago today
his parents tweeted this we appreciate
President Trump's recent comments about
our family we are proud of otto and miss
him hopefully something positive can
come from this now to world reaction no
other country has more at stake tonight
from their summit than South Korea
that's where senior foreign affairs
correspondent Greg Pell cot is right now
the ink wasn't even dry and the
declaration President Trump in North
Korean leader Kim jong-un signed at
their historic summit in Singapore
promising complete denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula before the global
naysayers zeroed in Iran which recently
saw the Trump administration back out of
its nuclear deal had a warning for
Pyongyang the u.s. administration's
failure to honor its commitments makes
us watch mr. Trump's behavior with
pessimism and I think that North Korean
government should handle this with full
vigilance China is showing signs of
backing out of international sanctions
against the north
thinks their grip should be eased UN
resolutions say that if North Korea
respects and acts in accordance with the
resolutions then sanction measures can
be adjusted which could include pausing
or removing them in South Korea the
country with a most at stake president
moon jae-in admitted he'd been nervous
before the summit and wished for the
best
I spent a sleepless night I sincerely
hope that it will open a new era of
denuclearization peace a new
relationship between the two Koreas in
the United States they might be losing
more sleep after president from
suspension of u.s. and South Korea joint
military exercises defense officials
here say they have to figure out the
exact meaning of the trump pledge
experts who see the drills as a
defensive bulwark against North Korea
are edgy it's a very symbolic also very
practically share as well because South
Korean practical
yeah yeah in the most common still
locals who have had their peace hopes
raised before watched the summit
coverage closely they who live daily
under the threat of war seemed happy to
see President Trump and North Korean
leader Kim exchanging pleasantries not
barbs it's better to meeting beta faith
rather than the paper to paper in
face-to-face is good yeah I want to keep
you want me it's Wednesday morning here
in Seoul Secretary of State Pompey
arrives here later today to explain the
results of the summit especially perhaps
the decision by President Trump to
suspend those military exercises here in
South Korea and then to plop the way
forward including more talks with North
Korea and then some Chris thank you Greg